so the dhs secretary mayorkus grilled by
senators and kind of revealed that he
didn't actually know that much about his
newly hired disinformation czar despite
calling her he was quite clear that she
was eminently qualified take a look
she has for starters consistently
misinformed the public about the hunter
biden laptop story and spread the lie
that it was russian propaganda she has
used social media and the public to
launder propaganda herself were you
aware of this information when you chose
her everything i've just shown you i was
not
how could you not be uh
did you do any research on her was the
department aware of her tick-tock videos
senator
uh either they're really quite
precocious um uh senator um i was not
you got the little mary poppins
reference there right they're really
quite precocious he's so funny senator
kennedy all right so 20 gop led states
are threatening to sue over the
disinformation board and republicans
making an issue over the lack of vetting
for the new disinfo chief nina janko
with newly uncovered video shows her
dismissing concerns about critical race
theory in schools watch this critical
race theory has become one of those
hot-button issues that uh the
republicans and and other you know
disinformers um who are engaged in
disinformation for profit frankly there
are plenty of you know media outlets
that are making money off of this too
have have seized on it's no different
than than any of the other hot button
issues that you know allow
disinformation to flourish it's it's you
know weaponizing people's emotion
yeah so you get it yeah um pete let me
start with you on this so she's she what
i loved is when she said um
if you find yourself getting emotional
there's a good chance that someone is
just manipulating you
so just just like cool yourself down and
say you know i'm just being manipulated
i'm not going to let it happen to me
because i know what they're up to
you're right and the other statement in
the other part of that statement was the
republicans and other
disinformers as if there are other dis
we know the republicans are disinformers
and the other ones that disinform too
and all those parents that are
protesting at the school boards because
they really are all in it for the profit
yes uh this is it is it is a dripping
irony of our moment that the person in
charge of the governance board on
disinformation is herself a disinformant
intentionally on one side side of the
aisle mayorkas may not have known
exactly what she said but nate no doubt
about it the people that hired her knew
exactly who she was and knew exactly
what her political inclinations and
instincts are and that from the she's a
dc 30-something uh dc creature that went
to georgetown and thinks that same way
that bubble thinks which is one side of
the aisle are disinformants the rest of
us are the elites who inform those mega
crowders about what's acceptable and
they wanted it that way thankfully she
tweets and tick tocks and we know about
it maybe just maybe
she won't get this position but this is
indicative the department of homeland
security is supposed to keep us safe
after 9 11 that's why it was created
and instead it's facilitating open
borders on the southern border and
creating a governance board to censor
speech of citizens think it's lost this
way just a tad
jessica um do you think this is an
unfair criticism of her
no i
if there wasn't evidence for it like a
tick tock i could watch or a tweet i
could read
um and everything is recorded now and
people have to be conscious of that and
when you're part of a digital generation
that's something that you often find out
too late but this is something that
she's been doing as a professional and
stands by her beliefs and that's
perfectly fine it just may mean that
you're not suited for this particular
position that doesn't mean that there
isn't room for you in
the world and to have another great job
but this feels like a question of when
my orcis is just going to say this is
not worth it to me anymore and this is
what happens when everyone puts forward
nominees with every president right like
they want this person and this person
gonna end up a little bit too extreme
but maybe if we sacrifice this one for
this one we're gonna get this thing that
we want and maybe that's what's going on
here i believe him that he had not seen
the mary poppins video um someone on his
team i'm sure had and didn't think it
was going to be a problem and maybe
that's an indication of something that's
wrong with our times as well because
people do not think ahead as to what the
response is going to be from the other
side to people and this happens
constantly running absurd candidates who
have crazy past and you think oh they
won't find out about that drug-fueled
orgy thing or whatever they were doing a
long time ago
all right i wasn't talking about you
particularly
i know what you mean it's because
they're not they're not that many yeah
a lot of people have this kind of
background you need and um there's not
that many sort of stand-up folks who are
dying for these kind of jobs i don't
think these days in government or even
perhaps running for government but what
do you think about marcus's performance
there and this whole thing
you know every time my major speaks i
say to myself there's a perfect example
of a man who lies every time he opens
his mouth like the borders are secure
and um if if 18 000 people come through
a day if we lift title 42 it'll be fine
we got it covered you know i did the man
has never said a truth as far as i'm
concerned i don't believe him and i and
with all due respect i must tell you if
anyone in any place in the united states
should recognize that there's got to be
a vetting of an individual it's got to
be in washington dc when you're talking
about a white house or you know an
administration appointee this isn't like
in high school they're hiring a guy who
you know five years ago you know got
drunk or something we're talking about a
person who's going to be in charge of a
disinformation board or whatever they
want to call it and all of a sudden this
guy is mayorkas comes out lies again so
she's eminently qualified she's not
eminently qualified she's just the
opposite she has proven that she is not
qualified and you know this is what i
hate about politics anymore i hate the
fact people don't believe in right and
wrong and truth and justice anymore it's
about power and winning and lying on
your way to getting it it infuriates me
which makes me think of you greg oh well
thank you for that you know dhs should
stand for dumb hire secretary uh he
claims that he could not disclose how
they hired her as if it's if as if their
hiring pro their hiring process is
sacred
doesn't the government require
businesses to kind of
make their hiring practices
transparent fair like you have fair
hiring laws but they they're exempt and
i mean if this guy doesn't know who's
running the board if and he doesn't even
know who's running the border see what i
did there pretty pretty pretty good
she's nina is
it's normally
i would say a harmless person she's like
a walking twitter trend right she's a
poster child for all the lazy rumors
that end up trending on twitter like
she's taylor lorenz is a victim she
tweets about that crt is a right-wing
fear tactic uh laptop is russian
disinformation these are all what gets
the biggest clicks and retweets in her
bubble right so the big problem here is
not that she's silly the the singing
video's silly but it doesn't make her a
bad person nothing makes her a bad
person the problem is she's just
not unbiased
if you look at everything she talks
about and believes in she is swayed by
what gets attention in her world and
that makes her incredibly unqualified
they should have if they actually keep
this actual board
they have to really try to bend over
backwards to find somebody with a
centrist perspective somebody that they
might not like you know somebody that
like pisses you off 50 of the time and
doesn't tick you off the other 50
percent we know there are people out
there like that there's a lot of them i
mean you think i always would always do
something like bill maher as an example
because half the time i want to you know
throw something at the tv and then the
other time i'm going wow that's really
brave or that's really amazing
you got that's not this you're going to
know exactly what she's going to come
what side she's going to come down on
just by reading her tweets to your
points social media has made it very
transparent you're just saying that
because bill maher was nice about you
i don't think he knows who i am but
maybe
you're talking about like an ombudsman
right like a newspaper that has someone
who's neutral who argues with the
entertainment and with the newspaper
that that's what you need and i do love
that you pointed out that he said he
wouldn't discuss the inner workings of
the high-end process
first of all it's the united states
government you're using all of our money
that we hired this person
so you can't tell me that you can't tell
me how you hire the person because
you're hiring them with our money so
because he lied anyway um i had the
president and his vp at odds again
according to some new reporting this
time over an issue that they really want
to make a lot out of right now so when
we come back hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else